[Music]
none of us like to be humiliated
nobody does i don't you don't
none of us do i did an episode a couple
days ago called
10 reasons why you should never give up
and i got a lot of comments hundreds of
emails and comments and private messages
about
this is what's perfect timing i need to
watch this etc so what some people ask
and says
so if this is 10 reasons why i shouldn't
give up what are the reasons why i do
give up
right so i have four of them here to
share with you before i get into the
message
of the video one of the reasons why
people give up is they buy into other
people's comments and criticism
everyone's going to criticize you we're
going to talk about the top 10
criticisms here in a minute but people
buy into it the other one is
they set high expectations and
constantly not hit and meet him
if you constantly set a goal and you
constantly don't hit it
your words mean nothing to your spirit
and your mind anymore
so you keep setting goals but you're not
going to hit it because you keep saying
you're not hitting it right so they set
such
big goals and milestones and they keep
not hitting it eventually they throw
into town and say
i'm not going to do anything else so
they give up the other one is they said
unclear and confused they're unclear and
confused about the purpose so
the question always goes back to listen
why are you doing this business
why are you doing this what's the
purpose of you doing this why are you
making money why is it important you
keep
used to telling me you want to make a
millionaire why do you want to make a
million dollar your income why is it
important to buy a big house
why they want to make a hundred thousand
dollars a year or quarter million
dollars you're a half a million dollars
why do you want that nice car why do you
want to travel and see the world why are
you doing this why are you working so
hard
the more you ask that question and go
deeper where disconnect
not necessarily this disconnect the more
you don't give up but if this doesn't
connect it's only this
i'm making money because everybody else
is making money too empty doesn't have a
lot of weight behind it
why are you making money why are you
working so hard because i want to see
the look on my mother's face when she no
longer has to work
at the 99 cent store for the rest of her
life that was my reason i no longer
wanted to see the look on my dad's face
of working in a 99 cent store in
englewood which he worked for 15 years
i don't want to see that look but i
didn't know before once i got clear my
purpose cleared up right and many times
once we hit the goal we don't get clear
about the next goal again which you got
to continuously do
then the fourth one is the fourth one is
typically the one
they don't know how to come back
from a humiliating experience let me
explain what i mean by that
how to come back from a uh humiliating
experience look
have you ever gone to a sales
appointment or made a sales call and it
was so embarrassing
you were so embarrassed that you don't
want anybody to know about it
and has that ever happened with you and
your friends have you ever had an
experience where
a handful of your friends you're sitting
there and you talk about your goals and
dreams and what you want to build
you ever had any friends laugh at you
think about it or co-workers laugh at
you
or a mother father relative laugh at you
has that ever happened to you
have you fully failed miserably where
you told everybody gonna do something
and it never happened
and you wanted to hide in a smaller hole
and just get away from everybody right
humiliation is very difficult i remember
when that happened to me the first time
it's happened many times in my life i've
had many many humiliating
experiences that's it can crush you if
you don't fully understand it
because we don't want anybody else to
see that we said something and didn't
happen that hurts us that breaks us down
right
but i'm going to tell you the better
part of it if you go through that
experience
and you fully allow it to happen to you
and you dig deep and figure the bigger
part of life
out you're going to come out a whole
different human being let me explain
some to you here
i want you to think about your ronda
rousey okay ronda rousey ronda rousey
you hear different names on the way they
pronounce our last symbol let's just
ronda rousey
and you are on top of the world
everybody's watching how amazing of a
fighter you are
we're all fans everybody's rooting for
you think about this for a moment here
everybody is rooting for you right and
all of a sudden
you're on a jimmy fallon show and on the
jimmy fallon show
jimmy asks you about this girl you're
about to fight holly holm
and you say the following thing i want
you to watch what she says in the
interview before the fight she read
exactly who holly holm was
she said he's she's a 19 time boxing
champion never been beaten she's
undefeated she's dishes that she's that
and i know what she's going to do she's
going to try to beat me with a kick but
it's not going to happen because i
already know that's what she's going to
happen
watch what she says here in the
interview talk about your opponent here
this is your home
opponent here holly holm this is like a
nice person
yeah she's she's a nice chick you know
she's nice
i don't have anything against her it's
just a nice trick that's gonna lose but
yeah yeah yeah you're gonna lose that
what now do you pick the time
that you you're gonna win on this one no
uh this one's gonna be a much longer
fight because she's a
19-time boxing world champion with 100
takedown defense and like head kick
knockouts i mean she's
she's undefeated an amazing athlete i
think the biggest threat definitely to
me especially on paper and stylistically
and
she's the type of fire that you have to
be very very patient with i feel like
she's going to try and like
keep distance and keep far away from me
and get me frustrated
and to a point i'll make a mistake and
she can try and kick me in the head but
it's not gonna go like that
not the way she wants so you heard what
rhonda said now watch this this is
jimmy fallon there is no show on
national television that's more popular
than jimmy fallon right on youtube the
video's got right now six million views
so she says but it's not gonna happen no
one's gonna kick me in the neck
and what happens in the fight shot at
vicious kick exactly what she did she
knocked her out
in the neck and what's amazing is
there's one side
where if hollywood had said i'm going to
knock her out by kicking her upside her
neck no she didn't say that
rhonda said what was going to happen to
her and happened
let me say one more time you can find
somebody and they'll say i'm gonna knock
him out with an uppercut
and it happens great you're a hero but
you're the opponent ronda says
she's gonna try to be knocked me out
with a kick and it happens
is there anything more humiliating to
them than that
so then watch how she of what happens to
her a month month and a half nobody sees
it nobody hears about her nothing
then she's on ellen degeneres and look
what this made her do
look what point she got to did you i
mean did you worry for a minute like
could this be permanent did i really
hurt myself and maybe i won't
do this again no to be honest like what
i always think like
my hon honestly like my thought i was
like
i was like in the medical room and i was
like down in the corner i was sitting in
the corner and i was like
what am i anymore if i'm not this and i
was literally sitting there and like
thinking about killing myself in an
exact second i'm like i'm nothing i'm
like
what do i do anymore and no one gives a
about me anymore without this and um
to be honest i looked up and i saw my
man
travis was standing there and i was
looked up at him and
i was just like i need to have his
babies i need to stay alive
that was like
when you watch this interview and you
see
her pain you feel it you know how she's
saying i wanted to commit suicide and
i was sitting i'm like what else am i
gonna find if i can't do this who am i
what am i what am i doing
and then she's looking at travis and
saying but i want to have his kids and i
want to do this and i'm going to do that
and she's getting emotional you can feel
the pain
so here's the thing that it goes back to
she's on ellen degeneres
she's on jimmy fallon seven billion
people around the world
they know who this woman is she's become
a rock star
she's somebody everyone knows about but
she got humiliated
at the highest possible level think
about when she goes in the streets
how people are going to react to her and
what they're going to say about her
think about her best friends what they
say
her cousins her sis bro fam think about
gatherings oh
she got knocked out by holly think about
that for a moment
and i myself i'm a rondo fan but i'm
gonna tell you what feeling is one of
the most greatest feelings in the world
i'm gonna take this feeling tonight
you need to embrace this feeling cure
there is nothing
there are not a lot of feelings as good
as a feeling of redemption
of redeeming yourself look there's
something about
us as human beings and mostly
a lot americans were were about the
underdog story of coming back
and wanting to see somebody when big
this is generally how the energy is
around the world we like the underdog
so if the main person that's supposed to
win rhonda is facing khali some people
want to see holly win
but when this person gets crushed people
also want to see this person
redeem themselves and become a hero
that's the story of redemption
we like the story of redemption so as
much as you may be going through a
difficult time
and somebody said something to you was
it as public
of a humiliating event as rhonda's i'm
jimmy fallon
and ellen degeneres was it that public
then if it wasn't that public
guess what you still got a lot of work
to do because we're still not at that
level yet where the world knows exactly
what rhonda's doing but
the key is from the highest level to a
great one that everybody knows in their
space to somebody that's an entrepreneur
running a business
criticism is a part of it i'm going to
talk about the top 10 common criticisms
entrepreneurs get and you need to know
this before it happens to you
so you don't know my gosh are they just
telling me am i the only one that's
going through this
no i'm going to share the ones there is
there are hundreds i've heard i'm just
giving you the top ten so let's start
off with the first one number one
you're greedy all you care about is
money so when you become an entrepreneur
you're gonna hear friends and family and
some people say you're greedy all you
care about is money
and this is one of the most um it's
almost a misconception when people say
you you know all you care about is money
as if becoming an entrepreneur you make
more money the first two or three years
right you don't become an entrepreneur
and you make more money when you become
an entrepreneur you sacrifice your w2
salary because you no longer have a
steady income
you no longer have health insurance you
no longer have the steady check
whether you do anything or not you don't
have that anymore there is a lot of risk
to becoming an entrepreneur
so if somebody says you're only driven
by money the reality of it is
isn't it the employee that's more driven
by money who wants the money now
versus the entrepreneur who doesn't want
the money now wants it later
i kind of think this side is a little
bit more greedy
than this side at least this side is
trying to say i'm willing to delay it a
little bit and get it later on this side
saying i want it right now
right so who is really the greedy one
but they're going to convince a lot of
people
and make you believe that all you care
about is money that's all you care about
all you care about is money everything
cues about money that's a criticism
number two
you're not the same anymore this is a
difficult one because a lot of times
it's tough um it's tough for people to
hear a friend or family say you know
mario you're not the same anymore
you've changed i don't recognize you
anymore what
happened to you you used to be nice we
used to talk now you speak this language
of books and all this other stuff
as if you think you're better than us
you know i don't know what's going on
with you man i miss the old you
i miss this i missed it very common
another one
you don't have a balanced life you're
working too hard your life is not
balanced it's not healthy to have a life
like this
as you're working late nights you get up
early you leave early
it's you're supposed to be home at five
o'clock this isn't how life's supposed
to be
this is why people in europe are happier
because people in europe come home
earlier
they're over loud they have you know
this this 30 day vacations that
americans work too hard and you're too
driven and
too much about competition too much
about this too much about that you're
working way too hard
balance your life the key is to have a
balanced life which in reality
the same people that tell you to have a
balanced life watch 40 hours of tv per
week
they don't have a balanced life so what
balanced life
you want to tell me have a balanced life
to have all the shows on tv to be known
about
the people that make the national tv
show syndicate shows do well
are the ones that have the balanced
lives they're the ones that come home at
five o'clock and watch
all those televisions entrepreneurs
don't necessarily make them money
it's the traditional nine to fivers that
make all those nice shows do well
because they said come home and watch
those shows next you're too cocky man
you know you've been you're too cocky
you've changed a little bit
you're too cocky becoming too arrogant
you're becoming way too cocky and
arrogant lately
you know why i'm wearing this and while
i'm not wearing the same under armour
shirt i was wearing before
because paula mario came up and he told
me i forgot to do point number five so i
went from point number four to point
number six
and point number five is probably the
most important point in my opinion
and that is when people say man
entrepreneurs you are just
way too obsessed with your business all
you
ever want to talk about is your business
i am so sick and tired of hearing about
what you're doing with your business and
what happened this month and what
happened i don't care i don't want to
hear it
you're obsessed you're almost adhd
you're not hearing anything i'm telling
you you're manic you're
you're semi-obsessed with what you're
doing this is not healthy for you
and if you're new going through this you
may be confused yourself a little bit
because you're going to say maybe i am
obsessed
maybe i'm overbearing maybe i'm talking
about it too much but let me completely
make you think about it
help you think about it in a completely
different way here's what it is think
about a woman who's pregnant
seven months pregnant with their first
child what do you think
is what they're going to talk about
majority of the time their pregnancy
what happens if that same girl gives
birth to their first newborn child
and for the first however many years
what are they talking about their kid
what happens when a person is about to
get married and their wedding is three
months away all they talk about is their
wedding
what happens when someone's about to go
on their honeymoon they talk about their
honeymoon what happens when someone's
about to
you know they obsess with whatever
they're doing college class tests
finals they're involved in what they're
doing
and generally most people after school
when they get a job they're no longer
obsessed about
many things that they were prior to that
it's typically just regular day-to-day
stuff
that everybody else is going to get
obsessed with so you'll hear people say
oh you won't believe how friends show
did you see what happened on friends
today did you see who this person is
dating did you see that angelina jolie
and brad pitt and jennifer aniston and
all this other stuff
and did you see what happened with csi
and did you see what happened with
desperate housewives and did you see
what happened with this
while the most will be obsessed with tv
shows talk shows
other people's lives and they want to
question an entrepreneur's life about uh
you know obsession
you stay focused on what you're doing
and you keep your obsession at the level
that it is
uh because you know you're gonna be
criticized about that and don't
let the majority confuse you and make
you think that you have some problem
that you're being way too obsessed
about the project that you're doing with
that being said i'm going to go back to
the
patrick dressed up in the blue is it
blue am i wearing a blue
under armour workout shirt and i'm going
to explain to you point number six
here's point number six
six you set unrealistic goals man what
becoming a millionaire do you realize
who you are
do you realize how your grades were in
school you're a nobody man listen we're
nobodies we're just regular people
you think you're gonna make a million
dollar income come on now that's not
gonna happen to you
you're just a regular guy man come stop
buying all these dreams
unrealistic goals seven you're reckless
you're a little too risky you're way too
risky
you gotta slow your roll too risky
you're taking too many risks i'm
concerned about all the risk you're
taking
eight you're not happy you are not happy
you're not amazing that
other people want to decide whether
you're happy or not to me there's a big
difference between happy and content
there's being content and then there's
being happy a lot of times
we don't fully process the difference
between contentment and happiness
contentment is
somebody says i'm just content making 60
a year
and i'm good coming home i'm totally
fine i don't need to make more money i'm
completely comfortable where i'm at
i'm content but the happy person is but
i'm happy because i'm
creating i'm advancing i'm growing i'm
part of something bigger than me i'm
part of something that i've never seen
before you have no idea
what's about to happen the next three
six twelve months it's so incredible
this is creating this happiness for me
and other people think you're not happy
because you're in a hunt for something
else
number nine you're too competitive
you're way too competitive this one's
always a strange one when people
say you're way too competitive you know
why it's so strange let me tell you why
sometimes when people say uh you're too
competitive
uh i get confused because the first
question i asked myself you said i'm too
competitive yeah you're way too
competitive
what's your favorite sports team oh man
i love my cowboys
oh it's just i love the yankees man
listen i see all these sports teams
why do you why do you like sports so
much man there's nothing like sports you
know
oh you like sports would you watch
sports if there was no records do you
think golden state's going to have the
biggest best record of all time i don't
know what that's going to happen looks
like they may beat
chicago's and they may beat and this
person beat and that person knocked that
and this person beat
what is beat b to stem from competition
what is knock that stem from competition
what is ranking stem from competition
what is
who scores the most points per game stem
from competition who wants the most
champions
from stem from competition so the
difference is this it's not that
i'm too competitive it just so happens
that you may be a fan
and i'm somebody that's playing in the
stadium and you've chosen to be a fan
both of us are competitive you cheer
some play in the stadium now the play
people that play in the stadium they're
cheering for other people as well
because i cheer for great actors i cheer
for great athletes i cheer for all these
other guys
but i also chose to compete in the space
that i have
i also chose to want to dominate in the
space that i have because that's what i
chose to do as an entrepreneur
so you've chosen to just be a fan in
case
some of you that watch this and you say
man
that's that's the way you explain that
because i felt like i was being too
competitive i was paying to
because they said you're this you're
that now if you're not competitive in
the world of entrepreneurship you will
be out of business
very very quickly in the world of
entrepreneurship and by the way let me
tell you this
this is not about nine to five folks
because there's a lot of people that
work at a company and they have a job
but they they they
work as if they're so competitive and
they're driven and they're working on
themselves so much so eventually they
become a vp
senior vice president they become a
president company ceo the company and
they move up
because they're competitive they're
still having a w-2 but they're also
competitive and last point here you got
lucky
it's one of the common things you'll
hear when you make it you kind of don't
mind hearing that because when somebody
says that about you it means you've
already made it they'll say you got
lucky
you know you got lucky you know that
person helped you out you know this
person did this for you you know that
person did this for you and yes
yes because i asked for help yes because
we worked as a team
yes because we were willing to share the
success and the credit and the accolades
and all that stuff together
yes of course i don't mind that i don't
have a problem with being that
but they say it in a way as if to take
the credit away from you
that if they tried it they wouldn't get
lucky because you got lucky
look you can call me lucky all day long
i do not have a problem with the name
lucky and you shouldn't either if
somebody calls you lucky you should say
thank you for that compliment
i don't mind being called lucky i'd
rather be lucky than not lucky and if
you have a choice between the two which
one would you rather be
you're nobody nobody minds getting lucky
you you you choose to be lucky so
it's important to know this so when
those comments and statements are made
to you
you're not sitting there saying i'm the
only person that feels this way
no it's called welcome to the world of
entrepreneurship where criticism happens
at the highest level
and the more you move up just expect a
lot more before it to happen to you so
if you didn't get a chance to watch the
episode 10 reasons to never give up
uh you'll see the picture here mario can
we put the link up a priority let's put
that up so people can see it
and let's put the link on the bottom 10
reasons to never give up
you can click on the link on the bottom
or search it on the internet and you'll
find it watch that video because that
gives a completely different perspective
than this video
and then at the same time subscribe to
the channel
if you haven't already and if you want
more content you can always go to
patrickbetdavid.com to find more content
thank you for watching take care